you are a real housewife of Beverly Hill
I am a housewife which is crazy has that
sunk in yet no yeah I mean a little I
don't I'm probably gonna be the
strangest one on this show I'm imagining
because that you know I'm not like a I
don't do Botox or anything and I just
won't a probably equal who knows it's
still news it's hard to bust into a
group of people it's like going to first
grade and being the new girl in class
she may be the new girl but Sony's track
was destined to hold a diamond they
think harassing me for years to do and
actually my really good friend Lisa
Rinna was urging me you know kind of
pushing me a little bit she's like it's
gonna be fun it's a great group of girls
you're gonna love it you're gonna get
along with everybody and just just do it
so I did why was this the year that you
caved and said let's sign up for you
know what I think that the older you get
the more you realize that things don't
come your way all the time and so I
thought you have to say no to this it's
a once in a lifetime opportunity and
hopefully it won't destroy my family or
my friends or you know I won't be left
alone in my house with my cats but I
think it's gonna be fun
Sutton an actress Garcelle Beauvais are
joining Bravo's Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills for season 10 the first
season without Lisa Vanderpump you're
entering this group at an interesting
time when a figure at Lisa Vanderpump
who has been a mainstay has left it
right it has that been tricky to
navigate are you nervous at all about
that no why would I be nervous I've
never met her I'm sure she's lovely
but I'm not trying to replace anybody
and I would imagine that we have kind of
different personalities yeah because I'm
kind of goofy and weird but you know I
hope that people are receptive to
meeting somebody
new and you know and and I am me a cult
like I had nothing to do with anything
it just leave me out of it everyone
Sutton's obviously got lots of charm to
spare specifically southern charm I
can't be anything but my authentic self
I've picked up on that and I want my
suit I know what must door to me my
authentic self yes if you want to get a
feel for who Sutton is just step inside
her new West Hollywood boutique aptly
named Sutton how did life lead you to
this store like where have you been that
this is the step for you right now I
don't know you know I grew up in Augusta
Georgia and then moved to New York as a
dancer and got into I had to leave the
dance in the world because I was so poor
and became a Development Director for
raising money for a dance company there
and then got married and moved back to
Augusta then to London then out here to
California so in in the whole time I was
traveling a lot and which was so
fortunate and I think just seeing
everything but also maintaining my
Southern roots was really important to
me and I like the blend of that I've had
the space I told you for three years
when the storefront came I thought okay
this is it this is where I'm supposed to
be it's where I'm supposed to do this so
here we are
Petey got an exclusive look inside the
one of a kind of space I wanted to
combine all the things that I love which
is fashion or Dacor all in one place and
we wanted everything to be exclusive and
just things that you can't find the
store is set up like a house so you've
entered through basically my closet
you've worked backwards from the closet
you passed through a Phi Y a and a
powder room featuring a custom made of
wallpaper it's exclusive to me so if
anybody wants this print they have to
come to this store you know and I don't
even know Mike I want anybody else to
have the print also pops up in the
living space complete with an office
dining room and pantry all curated by
Sutton do you find yourself now
everywhere you go absolutely looking for
stuff in the store
yes it's exhausting and I need to start
turning off my brain at one point
because I think everybody wants to talk
about on top of the vintage finds the
store is stocked with exclusive fashion
collabs and a made-to-order couture this
is August Gary Couture and when he agree
I don't know what happened to my brain I
was meeting with with him and his team
and I said what if we do I'll just get
eight pieces in the window like art I
love it because it's a sculptural and
it's going to change every three months
and they're just going to bring us their
beautiful couture pieces to showcase as
art as it is art it is art and yes hit
the mecca of steps this past year yeah
at the Met Gala and I was really excited
that they brought this one for the
opening cuz it's so sparkly and at night
it's so pretty it's a very impact I can
only imagine driving by yeah yeah we
actually we locked up very secure was he
gonna say there's a lot of money in this
but you got good security don't come in
here only during normal business hours
so it's part batik part gallery the plan
is to change out most of the merchandise
which Sutton refers to as art every
three months to keep the space fresh and
yes everything inside from the fixtures
to the fashions is first sale are you
just gonna want to take everything
[Music]